[Music]
we're back it's 2021.
people thought they might not be back in
the new year
i i was ready i'm i'm a new trish this
year i'm
really good to see you i'm happy to see
the h3 crew and the family
i'm just i'm just happy so there's no
no drama no negativity coming from my
hand i'm so happy to be here and so
blessed and so honored oh thank you
she's killing it the podcast is killing
i'm really excited to be part of this
family for real wow
this is a new year i'm so you know what
i'm really excited to be back i'm happy
to see you i love the show we do
it's a it's just it's awesome i mean
look at what we've brought here
together this is amazing this looks like
you look amazing let me just say
you look amazing yeah you lost somebody
yeah i want
i'm afraid i so i don't know if i lost
weight trisha always thinks i look
skinny
always always i don't always tell you
look skinny have you ever showed up and
been like he looks fat today
be honest i think you look the same i
never think you look fatter yeah but
the definitely skinnier today you're the
only one that noticed
so so god bless you i think people don't
focus on weight as much as we focus on
weight like fat people focus more on
weight than like other people
to like ian you're probably like this
you're like robocop but you're like you
know how robocop when he sees criminals
he like
crunches their data you're like that for
fat people very
yeah i very like watch what people eat
i'm very just like analytical about all
that stuff but you look good i know you
do
by comparison because my shoulders look
fatter than yours today and
therefore now i need to lose 10 pounds
before next episode you think you're
sure so you measure it by how fat our
shoulders look
but you're you don't usually open o wear
open shoulder outfits um i do and i'm
usually tanner so i'm kind of like pale
which makes it look
fat look fatter i just need to be like
this yeah i also just gained weight
i was just making doughnuts at
mcdonald's every day so dude you're
living your best life
i'm living my best life for sure i mean
like sometimes
sometimes i wonder look i'm just gonna
make a decision to kill myself by eating
mcdonald's
and die young and go out doing what i
love yeah but i don't think it's like
killing yourself people say that
it's not killing yourself then we're all
killing ourselves by like existing in
the world of coven like we're killing
ourselves every day by leaving the house
yeah but that's true but you by eating
more mcdonald's you increase your chance
of death
sooner for sure and you lower your
quality of life too
because like your thighs rub and you
have to hobble around
my quality of life is better when i
mcdonald's i'm so much happier really
i've been so happy
so [ __ ] just be a monster just be it
just do it do you
moses do you care if she gains like a
lot of weight
that's a bad question he can't answer
that no he like but he also like doesn't
care he'll like
buy me donuts i'm like i'm trying to
lose weight and i feel like moses is a
fee like secretly a feeder yeah for sure
he always buy me know something i'm
going on a diet tomorrow and he's like
got some donuts for you
but it's nice i like when ela feeds me
sometimes she forgets
she like forgets for a day because ila
like is kind of
she wants the best for me right yeah of
course and so she
doesn't enable my eating very much but
sometimes she does and i'm like oh i
love you
what do you mean what's up what does
that mean though like enabling your
eating
like she won't she won't like give me a
dirty look because i got a triple
cheeseburger with bacon and eggs and
[ __ ] dog [ __ ]
that's not enabling that's just not
being disgusted by your eating yes yes
someday she's not disgusted by my ears
he enables my eating like
we'll we'll have food like five minutes
away on post me and i'll open a bag of
chips and then he'll like oh i'll have
some too instead of being like oh we're
just about to eat he's like i'll have
some of those chips too like he's very
much like that
enabling is like bringing home like you
said like
i'm being like let's go girl i need that
i need
more support when i don't want to eat
too he'll get something gross when i'm
like trying not to eat dinner if i'm
trying to like fast he'll get something
like i don't like like shawarma or
something i was like all right i won't
you know
how are you not fat he's gonna be you're
gonna be fat
yeah you are moses is gonna get fat as
[ __ ]
well that's good we'll look a little
better in pictures right now we're like
kermit the frog and miss piggy
so i feel like eventually we'll be
similar
well happy new years there's been um
happy new year there's been a lot that
has happened first of all let's explain
what we're doing here my goodness
we're all a great idea by the way that
you guys came up with ian did a great
set design yeah they did a great job
dan's always amazing like everyone's
amazing here like i love except for i
don't know zack i don't
i don't like love him but he lost a lot
of weight so good for him but i don't
know anything about that's great but
yeah you don't interact with him
yeah he's anyways but we love everyone
here
except zach he's not here he's part of
the h3
podcast so um
what we're doing here today is we are
bringing you not the streamies which we
all know is a corrupt and ridiculous
organization
they nominate you for the best podcast
every day yeah but there's
such a scam are they okay actually i
have been nominated for best podcast
like three years running but i go
and i never win it's always like dude
the last guy who won i never even heard
of but okay whatever he could be a big
deal
but anyway um it's like why isn't joe
rogan on it if they're really that legit
oh well he's like like a conservative
right like it's probably for liberal
people
liberals only what kind of resort show
is that i think that's every award show
in hollywood
huh interesting i never thought about
that way
i'm excited for this award show because
i'm actually nominated and i was named
you're nominated several times i think
but anyway
what we have here today is the steamies
as if to drinking the piping hot steam
it was like a steamy dump yeah i
that also went through my you could
think of it either way it's a steamy
dump
it's a steamy tea what it is is the real
award show
of 2020 that you wish was here but the
streamings are too much
cowards to actually cover what matters i
love yeah it's like the worst of the
worst we're like rewarding people for
being problematic for keeping us
entertained for keeping us a job like
we wouldn't have the headlines we
wouldn't be here without you folks
we need a theme song the steamies
bringing you the steaming turds of 2020
yeah
that's good and as always well not as
always but today we have a sponsor for
our steamy awards
sponsor of the steamies is
adamandeve.com adam and eve
who code h3 for 50 off plus free
shipping
wait we're not doing the ad we're just
going to okay we'll do that later
shout out adam and eve they're they're
the sponsor of the steamies maybe
they'll do it every year for us
we gotta we're working on it i moved to
a new agency and they're working on it
okay
anyways you know what's the problem with
getting sponsors on this show
is because usually what they do is they
buy like a year
worth oh and the thing is they're like
your show
could end any time i don't think that's
a possibility anymore i'm
i'm here until the end with you like to
then until like you fire me
or something people usually have to like
dump me so really you're clinging on
i'm clinging on okay man i'm in good
shape and now i'm in the family
so we're going to be doing oh my god
wait let me see so that's another thing
hold on there's way too much to talk
about
we gotta get an award show too oh so
moses what was this like 10 million
dollars i mean i've never seen a diamond
like that in my life
it's crazy it's crazy it's but like
that's ridiculous
like what how many carrots is that nine
how can you who are you why are you
buying nine carat rings i mean what
seriously i think you know what's so
great and i i've said this before now
it's a real diamond or is it like a
sarconium
whatever it's real
um no i always say this like don't judge
people based on where they live or
anything like that because like if i
would have judged moses from like our
first meeting
him in this like little tiny makeshift
apartment in like this like building and
like
the ghetto i would have been like okay
but he saved his money he never buys
anything
carrots bro did you know this
[ __ ] could buy a nine carat
diamond ring
i was i was i felt bad when i thought i
was like like because i
he had plans like renovate his building
and not anymore
and i'm like i'm sorry that you took
your renovations holy [ __ ]
but you know what it says to me it says
he's invested in our relationship
because you know people are like he's
using trust for money and i was like you
know what
he put half for the house he invested in
this ring for me that's a nice
yeah that's my you know it's like the
dream that is insane
yeah he's he's yeah he's very yeah get
you a guy that doesn't spend money on
himself
that's the motto of that either kind of
did that to me really
i think so because you're kind of like
conservative with your money i just no
it's not yeah i'm cheap i just don't
want to buy stuff
oh that's like a dream for like honestly
yeah because if you like to shop you
can't have two shoppers in the family
so god forbid two shoppers nobody can
survive in that
yeah anyway so you're engaged by the way
which which
i want to talk about that but first let
me talk we have just so much going on
here today
uh we were gone for two weeks and we're
getting overwhelmed here let's take a
step back
i want to uh ian can you please announce
that the categories that we'll be
celebrating today
yeah you want you want the first one now
now ian
as you'll notice is wearing a space-aged
kovid
mask ian had covid he's recently got
over it he doesn't have covey he tested
negative he had covered like
um how long ago did you yeah a little
over a month ago when i got the
diagnosis
whoa he's good but he was really sick
for a while
oh and so we put on the space age helmet
not because he's actually contagious but
just because i thought it would be funny
i don't believe that i feel like you
think he might still be contagious so
you're like put a helmet on ian well
we'll make it part of the show well the
truth is this is some weird gofundme
that we bought like
seven months like seven months ago for
like 250 bucks
it's so ghetto it's supposed to have
like a fan with the battery
it doesn't work show them the gloves the
glass
they have gloves so you can itch your
face it's just yeah
it's your face for us ian it's hard to
see because it's so glossy well put your
hand in the glove
go ahead that looks cool is this not the
best award show folks i mean we're
pulling all this stuff
that's amazing all right ian's ian's
trying to best to get his hand in that
club but it's not it doesn't appear to
be too easy
hell yeah thank you wow what a spot
oh that was so only here on the 2020
steamies everybody
you know this is meant to prevent you
from getting sick
but it's like a covid simulator
i feel like i still have it really like
i can't breathe i'm tired
oh it's hot you have a fever
[Laughter]
yeah please what categories do we have
here today with there we're celebrating
pleasing
go ahead all right we've got a little
presentation to show
each one so they did this in three days
the h3 crew did this in three days it's
amazing
no we've been working on this no he's on
saturday he put up these videos we've
been planning it for a while but ian did
ian you the crew did great i mean all
all praise beads
this is amazing go ahead oh we're going
to do the categories
god i i just there's so much to talk
about so wait let's talk about your
engagement before we do that i thought
we should do this category okay
oh my god everyone's like what is this
show such a mess
because we have so much time okay so
tell me how did moses think uh proposed
to you
i definitely wasn't expecting it because
i was stressed as oh my god
people thought i was like in blackface
that day because we had a shoot
planned for oh was that the jasmine
thing yeah but also we are dressed as
jasmine jafar
which is like the bad guy from the movie
and she's like a slave to him in that oh
i thought you were aladdin
no but you guys do daddy dom [ __ ]
you do huh oh yeah but are you
are you don't are you submissive or
dominant no of course a submissive are
you abba i'm teen oak
do you know oh my god that's so crazy
anyways um no it definitely abba's daddy
or dad in hebrew
auntie nokia is baby girl gross anyways
um
so so yeah we i had this shoot planned
for a while and i just
i got a really crazy spray tan the day
before
and so well i don't know i guess he just
knew that i wanted to be glam so he
thought me as princess jasmine was like
my glam
but that was actually a cosplay that's
not me oh so were you a little upset
that he proposed then
no i definitely wasn't upset i was so
excited i just was like you're like
my belly was out i was like oh my god
he's putting me to the side and i have a
fat belly and i'm just like oh no and my
nails were broken
because i had video shoots the day
before so my nails were like short
but you didn't know he was gonna propose
no i would have got my nails done like i
was
i was the video was really nice yeah
i wonder if we should watch it it was
really sweet i think i don't know how
many people have seen it it was really
beautiful you were
you were you were so very happy and
it was a very joyous video i was very
shocked for like
so many reasons when we just got this
house so i literally did not think he
was gonna like get a ring like that was
the commitment for me so i was like
we probably won't have a ring for a
couple months maybe it's not even our
one year anniversary yet so i'm like
maybe our one year anniversary like
march 5th like 14th and
oh you guys will be together for a year
in march yeah we met wow
time that's crazy so i just wasn't
expecting it but i was really happy like
the first thing he said too was like i
called your dad which was so crazy
because like who thinks to call
like my dad and my definitely so happy
not any guy i think i have data that has
met my dad once only once moses has met
him a multitude of times they talk all
the time like they like he loves moses
like
and he said they talked like an hour and
really wow look at that
my dad your i called your dad i was like
how'd you get his number like anyways it
was so complicated and then he was like
he's like he said he'd be so he's so
happy and well a lot and i was like oh
my gosh so then i was like crying so
that
then i was crying because he was
proposing and i was like oh my god i
can't believe his hair and then what
about when you saw the ring
oh my god i lost it i mean that was to
me like i don't
i think that's why i'm so happy like
like nothing bothers me with him anymore
i'm just like the ring
you're like dude whatever whatever is
wrong with you just talk to the ring
i can't believe this i like we looked up
like jlo's to ben
get a mortgage on your uh on your place
he became a diamond broker he wanted
this it's a blood diamond
probably no um uh no but like honestly
like i looked at it like we looked at
jayla and ben affleck's like ring and it
was only like
five or six carats and this is like
enough oh losers idiots
no halo either because i always know no
shade anyone who has a halo i'm like
i hate like engagement works with halo
so i thought he might get wait what's a
halo the halo's like the little diamonds
around it
will make it a little better pathetic
it's not pathetic it's cheap
levy and [ __ ] no but can i just tell
you like
he cus he designed it but i had shown
him like a dream ring of mine that
looked just like this
and when i saw that he like and i showed
him maybe once so like the fact that he
remembered like
one time when i was probably like high
or something i was just like wow that
was really cool i like
yeah because it's forever you know and
it fit my fat fingers he was so
he's so smart because he always listened
to me i would go into like stores and
try on rings and
they would never have my size and they
would like measure way to go moses
so well i got to say that i am very
happy
i'm very excited it's so crazy that
you're going to be my sister
i know we're like actually family now
that's so crazy
and you're invited to the what we
already planned the wedding dates i
won't say the dates but we already have
them planned like
it's so weird yeah oh you you have a
date yeah like
we have three because we have la israel
and maui for real so we have the three
dates why maui
um because he's never been and we
watched an adam sandler movie called
just go with within he got married at
this hotel in hawaii and so now i want
to get married there too
but who's going to go to maui like our
family like you guys the immediate i'll
come to maui yeah it'd be like my like
this is the second wedding this one's
[ __ ] i was already at the one i was
already at two of them because i'm gonna
have to go to israel and
right so la will be over like i'm going
to go to three [ __ ] weddings two of
them destinations
for you guys that's our bougie though
like well
yeah but who else could do that my
family really
yeah so we're gonna all be having fun
like crazy you know
like think it's gonna be so much fun
like shane will probably be like my best
man so like they'll come over like it'll
be like oh that would be nice yeah it's
gonna be like
oh i'm so excited because i get like
married in like jaffa which is like the
old like city and we're gonna have like
aladdin and jasmine themed like
don't [ __ ] do that i don't know like
white and gold like pretty like classy
don't
do that moses don't allow that buried at
the end of the day you can't go to jaffa
and get married as jasmine and
aladdin that's crazy it was themed ask
like you're not gonna allow that right
you don't know what we're talking about
it's like it's like the one they get
married at the end they have white and
gold
outfits and it's inspired by that it's
not like aladdin you're not gonna be in
tan face no i'm not gonna be in black
hair like well i did want to read
there was one congratulatory tweet that
i thought was funny i don't know
that i thought wanted to read right out
the top
keemstar had a congratulations for both
of us
how sweet he said ethan klein he
misspelled my name
my last name k-l-i-e-n for someone who's
thinking about me
on chris oh by the way he sent this
tweet on christmas morning
not because he's on the east coast so he
sent this tweet at 12 o'clock christmas
day with his family he's sitting around
drinking eggnog
the fire's crackling he's with his
daughter and he goes
he's like oh ethan you could climb
how weird should you like make my
proposal like about you then
like tweet that i was like oh that's
kind of weird but he goes ethan klein
has had the worst year
ever one he lost subs i don't know what
he's talking about
with that on h3 i feel like you guys
gain subs on here yeah we had a great
year
lost sponsors um it's okay that's true
true lost respect i mean you could
debate that
thank you dan well said gained weight
true lost weight no now you well overall
i did gain a lot of weight
but i think it's funny for him to attack
me on that because like i'm started
antidepressants and i'm working on all
this stuff and you gain a lot of weight
when you take antidepressants or some
people do my fat ass did
he's also super fat and short yeah he's
fat chain smoking freak
when i went for him i came for his
fatness like fat people can go for his
fat and i'm like you're also a foul take
it from one
fat idiot from another you're a fat [ __ ]
uh and well then and then the the uh the
perfect
uh number five was now trisha paytas is
his sister-in-law i
legitimately feel sorry for him he's so
jealous he's so jealous of that
dude keemstar would keemstar would
castrate himself for a chance to be with
you i get a feeling
no for sure i've not met him at parties
he's definitely like
i know you'll deny him like you're so
gross but like you know people always
say that and then they always try and
like [ __ ] you and you're like okay
well there's a reason why you think
every dude who you ever meet wants to
[ __ ] you i think this dude likes
keemstar
it's so true yeah you know they do when
you like like reject it and then they're
like oh she's so gross what are you
talking about
yeah i would never [ __ ] her it's like
they say that when they get rejected so
like that's how you know
otherwise people would never say i do
feel like keemstar legit wants to [ __ ]
you
for sure because a normal guy that like
doesn't want to [ __ ] me or not attracts
me would never be like she's such a [ __ ]
ugly [ __ ] like only guys who like got
rejected say that
no like normal guys right right right
right right right so wait let me go
[ __ ] dumbass phone apple like logan
paul would never be like trish is a fat
ugly [ __ ] because he's like i
obviously would never [ __ ] that girl
because there's different leagues but
keem is so like
mad that i've like rejected him so you
rejected keemstar
for sure he's definitely been like weird
at parties like i wouldn't say like
tell me everything i've actually met him
like twice in person
and yeah and i think it was just i don't
know i think
what do you say i honestly can't
remember because i was with my
ex-boyfriend at the time tell me about
so you were together with somebody and
keemstar came up to you at a party was
he drunk
um i think so and what did he say what
was his demeanor you just give me
details as much as you can remember yeah
really because i don't want to get it
like off like i don't want to miss
anything well he's going to call you a
liar anyway so care say whatever
i know but i try and be credible i'm a
new trash like i'm trying to get out of
credible
i'm a new girl i'm a new woman i'm like
you know what i mean i'm engaged i'm
happy
um just i don't know does i feel like
he's very touchy with people i saw him
touch you with like a little violet and
he's very just touching yeah and like
with me
can you imagine you start touching you i
feel like you would like
i feel like your arm would turn black
wherever he touched you
um he was fine he's just really
unattractive in person and that's it i
mean there's no shade i'm not i'm not
the most attractive person
you know well anyway he said ethan if
you see this i hope you have a much
better
2012 and i'll say that the fact that my
brother-in-law and trish are engaged is
a great way to start the year
i love you both and i'm just very happy
and excited for the future that you guys
hold so
congratulations moses great job and you
pulled out all the stops god damn dude
you know how i propose to ela
not as good as this [ __ ] what
you do it's actually it's so
embarrassing you're gonna get mad at me
if i tell you no tell me i need to know
this
we were in mexico my parents lived there
and i was always planning to get
married to ila but i was with my mom
we're staying with my parents
and my mom starts being so annoying she
goes
you have to propose to her you have to
get married now
and she starts like putting all this
crazy pressure on me and she gives me
like one of her old this
how did i succumb to this why would you
say you had to get married you're so
young
well we had been together for a while i
don't know why but anyway anyway
like we had already been together for
like four years or something so she's
like you better keep her she'll like
leave you which
i guess my mom was like yeah that was
kind of what my mom's like she's going
to leave you i was like
she wouldn't yeah and so
dude honestly how do i even set tell
this without what
you were on the toilet yeah really yeah
you or her so i took the ring that my
mom gave me
i put it in a bag of baby wipes
and i put and i put it by the bed and i
was on the toilet pretending to poop and
i said ela can you grab me the baby
wipes
no and then oh this is cute really is
this real that's
cute this is cute that's very you yeah
it was
and so i said can you grab me the baby
wipe so she brought the bag of baby
wipes over and i said can you pull one
out for me
and the ring was in the bag of babies
yeah was she so excited she yeah no she
was stoked i mean like we talked about
it she knew we were gonna get married
but she was most like
i think she was like confused
yeah were you guys doing videos already
yeah
so maybe yeah you should have done
something more creative you put effort
into your videos
that wasn't the vibe though back then it
wasn't the vibe to be like
cute it was all just like you want to be
gross
yes okay no i didn't film it or anything
that was just
i just decided in the moment like i'm
gonna propose to ela
and i'm just gonna try to make a joke
maybe she'll
because it's the last place thing she's
gonna expect the ring and the bag of
baby wipes oh yeah
and so what happened then did you guys
take pictures like did they come in your
parents and like take pictures
there's no nothing to commemorate it not
the ring there's nothing how much was
the ring or how many carrots was the
ring
the ring was trash did you upgrade since
so ila she bought an engagement ring
when we were in mexico for like uh
it's just a really sweet cute little
ring but it's only like 100 bucks wait
you didn't pick out the ring
we went and picked it up together but
then you got it and surprised her
no she we bought it on the spot oh okay
that's cute
okay that's it um and how many carrots
carrots like a hundred dollar ram oh
it's a hundred dollars yeah
and you never upgraded never that's cute
though i think that's cute i think i
like the ring it's just like a little
red stone and a gold band oh
but that's like humble our men are yeah
we were not rich at the time by any
means
and by the way so far so good right
man the marriage is working that's
amazing and you guys are like
ballin which goes to show once again
it's all about showing off your wealth
and whatever like that like
i feel like i spend way more like people
think i'm like richer than i am because
i spend so much i feel like wow she's
balling like it's like
yeah i make a lot of money but i also
like spend a lot you guys have it like
in the bank set for life
like that's better you would be too if
you didn't have like 10
70 000 burkas right why won't they
break you know i like flashy i like to
live my life because i could die
tomorrow so i like to live my day but at
the same time there's something to be
said about
like being humble and saving money like
that's cute too thank you but i will say
once my lease is up on my
dog [ __ ] tesla acts i'm getting a rolls
royce
well i don't know i don't want this
weird rolls-royce life that you have
like
you get into weird your life is so weird
in that rolls-royce it scares me
anyway so that's that was that
congratulations you guys i'm so happy
and i'm just
i'm i'm i'm just i'm very i'm very happy
it fills me with joy to see you guys
both so happy i'm so excited
about the wedding it's like clout yeah
about
no i'm kidding we were gonna come i was
just gonna because we were beefing i was
like we can't make it joke oh my god
and his family is so happy his whole
family was very happy over in israel
like everyone shane is more clout
than us shane is like mega wedding clout
yeah for sure yeah
we gotta just get the most clout we can
okay you got any clout coming to the
wedding oh
he's got some private he's got some
private clout let's go dude
he's super cloudy no he's got cloudy
yeah if his clown comes it's going to be
cloud city
you need a smaller one we got more clout
than we do in terms of people you know
this is bouge itself
[Laughter]
okay so anyway yadda yadda you guys got
marry or proposed
kim was a douche okay let's do the award
show sorry everybody
adam and eve you know you know
uh adam and eve is the number one place
to buy
fun and adventurous how do you say it
without saying it
fun and adventurous item for him and her
naughty thoughts
doll toys for him and her and when you
use code h3 you can get these naughty
toys for 50
office free shipping if you're in the us
and canada and guess what
else you also get toys for him twice for
her they get thrown some free bonuses
some movies
and that's really cool because i haven't
seen that code anywhere else on youtube
where you can get the additional stuff
you get the movies you get the treats
you get the smacks you get the bonuses
and it's all free
folks and you might be staying at home
but now you can play at home with adam
and eve
you can do that with 50 off with the
code h3 and honestly it's really really
good you guys all
get the g-spot vibes are going to change
your life they're going to be amazing
i got something today called the [ __ ]
liquor look it up on adam and eve
amazing it's cool it's like a little
tongue it's like a little i wish i would
have brought it it's like a little
triangle i kind of want to look up a
photo of the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] liquor it's turquoise i showed
it and it's
it's amazing it's actually it feels like
5 000 tons going like
100 miles a minute that sounds bad like
what was it called the [ __ ] liquor
licker from adamandeve.com
it's teal they have lingerie also that
goes up to like 4xl so you can get that
for 50
off no you guys what the [ __ ] is this
oh my god what the [ __ ] is this here's
the [ __ ] looker
okay intense remote control rechargeable
[ __ ] liquor
item number e349 this will change your
life it's 70
but with the code h3 you can get it for
35 dollars which is a really good deal
50
off 50 no but this is really cool look
it like see all the little tongue
motions that can go around and the
little bunny
lets your partner control it for you so
you can control this is really really
cool actually so like
um how do they get 50 off that's so
crazy it's insane and it's super cute
it's discreet
fifty percent off is really good you
could even bring that to like dodger
stadium with the little fan just looks
like a fan nobody would know just
throw it up your skirt like no one's
gonna know it why does it have a fan on
the edge
no that's the tongue's that circle oh it
just literally slaps your [ __ ] yeah it
goes
oh my god it's it has 12 12 and 10
speeds and functions it's really really
good honestly guys that's how he is like
life changing you really
i just found out what a dick sleeve is a
dick sleeve i don't think that's the
proper term but
that's what you said apparently there's
dick yeah
you can this is just an idea for the
guys at home it's for vibrating you put
you cover your whole
dick and like this whole like it's like
a vase it's like
all these ornate trimmings and
everything and you just cover your whole
it's amazing it gives different
simulation it has swirls it has a little
like nubs on it it's vibrations it's
really really
good it looks like hell razor it's so
good it's got this giant penis head with
like nails coming out
it's good inside either either hole
whatever hole you want to put it
would you [ __ ] hellraiser you know the
guy with the pin heads or pinhead
i don't know because he probably has
pins coming out of his dick well maybe
that's what it's modeled after
probably that guy probably got good dick
bruh
[Music]
oh i've seen that that's like really old
no i am engaged
good answer all right and eve.com
playing at home get a 50 off with code
h3 plus you get added bonus free gifts
free
movies free shipping if in the united
states canada get the [ __ ] liquor with
the code h3 adam and eve
and get a [ __ ] sleeve i mean that's good
whatever that is
[Laughter]
all right now let's get on with the show
the steamies take a huge steaming dump
on your partner is there dump toys i
think that's illegal
pooping on each other i think in like
porn you can't even find around pornhub
oh that makes sense but what about
pooping toy it what would you talk
vetoing for people
i don't know about that but why can't
you poop on your partner
uh i think just like filming it i don't
know filming it i think it's probably a
health hazard
because you can pee on your partner i've
seen that plenty in porn um but that's
not really allowed like on porn sites
like they'll like bc
yeah you can't because visa will like
take away like pornhub issues he's just
like
no peeing we crossed the line at peeing
interesting
yeah pornhub took down all the amateur
videos
yeah i heard about that they took away
everything very i'm so glad because
people re-uploading
it it's all down now but that that's
actually good because i heard that they
had a real problem with like
underage and weird all kinds of weird
really messed up stuff there so that's
great that they did they did that i
think
i think so fantastic all right
all right what's our first uh what's our
first category please ian
it's uh biggest covidient biggest cove
idiot starting off with a bang this is
my favorite this is a good category
great titles whoever thought of this
thank you very much biggest covidient of
2020 let's review the nominees please
biggest
addison may bad press for addison's new
movie remake movie production
shut down a coving tested site to film a
part of the movie
nikita dragon nikita posted a video on
instagram from the party where she says
that she was the one who planned the
entire thing
so we can give it up to miss nikita
dragon for that party i guess
so i went and got a kobe 19 test and it
actually came back positive
i
[Music]
were seen at the party on social media
including james charles
oh i don't deliver any tea i drink
coffee
parents dixie mark heidi and charlie
charlie dixie and noah beck decided to
go on a year-end trip
to the bahamas charlie and her sister
have both been ignoring this whole
situation
jake paul hosting a house party over the
summer
despite official covid 19 warnings
against large gatherings
wow beautiful thank you
ian oh my god in this envelope we have
the biggest covet idiot now if you guys
are wondering how the votes were tallied
we put out a anonymous form
on twitter and we had over 45
000 votes cast now i do not even know
the winners this was cast anonymously
filled out by ian
so i'm very excited what is your feeling
on who is
going to be the biggest cove idiot oh my
god of course i hate influencers i hate
them and they're all i know
they're actual murderers like james
charles was like
the most likable in those clip i was
like oh james isn't bad compared to
these
right idiots well and then there's one
who wasn't even on the list where uh
faze banks in the phase clan
had like this huge banger that was just
these people are psychotic it's like
it's so
psycho it's also like just
the cockiness i don't give a [ __ ] like
yeah
the logan paul thing is my favorite
because he didn't know he's being filmed
jake no that was logan who was like i
don't really give a [ __ ]
and i was like oh true color is coming
out that was i thought we had jake twice
oh that's logan
yeah that was logan oh that's what's up
tanner's like hey i was hanging out with
you all week and i have covered just so
you know he's like i don't really give a
[ __ ]
i was like dude what the [ __ ] wrong
they both deserve to be canceled because
he also like kicked his dog off a boat
earlier this year like last year
yeah and like for like a thing you could
see someone pushing the dog off
like that should be canceled like you're
being oh i so who
in your opinion is the biggest cove
idiot if you can take a guess
um i'm gonna just go ahead and go with
i would personally vote nikita i did
vote and i voted for nikita because she
just keeps throwing parties never
wearing masks
in elevators with people not wearing
masks i voted for jake paul
because he threw a bunch of parties and
he also is infamous for saying
uh covet is a hoax which we love all
right
so do we have a drum roll do we have
some kind of uh
suspense oh okay add it in post
and the winner for biggest covidia 2020
is jake paul
congratulations cancel him forever we
have uh
the the breakdown jake paul won with 41
that's a resounding victory tana was in
second with 24
james nikita the emilio and logan paul
in last
we had some writings actually noticeable
write-ins addison ray and bryce hall and
our very own ian the intern with two
votes in the salary to play
two votes did that hurt it's stunned a
little but probably well deserved
oh poor ian well congratulations
and we have i think we have an award for
jake as well right that we'll be sending
to him
we'll be mailing he's moving to miami so
thank god we got the whole video
we'll find him and and does this have
his name engraved
yeah oh right so jake paul we are going
to be getting this
engraved that's a cool award with the
pink cup just because it's steamy
just because it's oh oh the tea okay
yeah yeah so jake
and it was eight dollars i see it's
still on here so making big investments
we should take a
dump on it and send it to him i'll put a
little steamy in there and understand it
so jake paul biggest covidient idiot
2020 we're gonna be sending this to you
congratulations
he's the worst thank you he might be the
worst actually
yeah i really dislike him so i think
okay that was fantastic our next
category wow this is so much fun
is this not exciting i never saw those
clips like ew people should
look at those and be like these people
don't deserve their eight million dollar
houses you know what you mean like
i just wish i mean i'm not going to say
what someone deserves or not but i don't
deserve it i just i just wish that you
would just
stop being such a selfish [ __ ] jake
dan what's happening good morning conor
mcgregor i know you're probably beating
up old dudes in a box
you is notorious for playing sounds in
the background
while the show's good i don't give a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's like so like i hope
i won't wish it i hope someone he knows
gets kova because it's like
the worst thing to deal with but you
know what the fact that they don't even
care like they wouldn't know
it's like psychotic and like you're in
l.a
where there's no hospital beds and
people get strokes and heart attacks
can't even go to the hospital like you
had to drive your mom to orange county
yeah they're like evil that's like evil
that's like an evil person and i don't
like that there you go like nikki is an
idiot james is an idiot
congratulations logan you suck pound it
for the idiots
hate them sorry my big ring okay oh yeah
knock it like dude
dude you could kill someone with that
thing [ __ ] carve this down on earth
with that
all righty our next category in uh it's
biggest clout goblin
biggest clout goblin now what we mean by
clout goblin is just
i'm not really quite sure what it means
but i feel like you know what it means a
clout
goblin for sure you can just picture
someone that's just right who's just
hungry for clout
and they're willing to associate and do
anything to get in the limelight to get
attention and it's just more like not
even being like
they're just so disingenuous about it
they just like are so obvious about it
like you're gonna hang out with a 16
year old when you're
you know what i mean that's like a clown
goblin you're really gonna go i think i
know who you voted for
well let's see your nominees dan our ian
or abe whoever is doing it
biggest clout goblin jake
paul jake paul coming in strong i know
you're probably beating up old dudes in
a bar right now
maybe you're jacking off because you're
sick of [ __ ] your wife i mean she's a
four connor you could do
a lot better but happy monday dixie
tamilio
who's one person that you really want to
collab with
trippy read on a song would be very cool
that's my sister charlie oh yeah hi nice
to meet you
so she's kind of the start of all this
brought everything together
bella thorne bella thorne made one
million dollars in 24 hours on only fans
causing new restrictions in the way the
app works for other content creators big
head
it's a it's a snip snip big ad it
prevents me
from getting you pregnant
why are you not telling me last night
i didn't know how austin mcbroom
i got enough kids but i'll make you my
son okay
[Music]
ill great i know
i found a youtube video where i reached
out to some of my favorite celebrities
and asked them to recommend a product
for my makeup routine
miss gigi hadid miley cyrus i thought it
would be cute to dm miss
rosalia alexa to me rita ora i thought
that i would dm
somebody very very legendary
hi sir
that's one video of james charles like
ew yeah that was gross
so i have here the winner of biggest
clout
goblin now i myself voted for james
charles
because obviously his association with
like a 16 year old girl who's just super
popular yeah and i get the sense he's
really just using him
her to ev to rejuvenate his career
the dolan twins did you see that clip of
like him with shane like praising how
much he loved the shining character that
was like he said was ghetto and racist
and he's in the club he's like
that character like changed my life and
he was like in a video with shane
telling him that he's just such a
whenever it's useful for you he goes to
the next person whereas emma chamberlain
where's the dolan twins he just leaves
them aside for the demilios
that whole thing of damning celebrities
no one cares this show is
very anti james charles oh i will say
that
okay ready drum roll please
biggest clown goblin of 2020 is
james
they love you and another resounding win
for james charles 40 percent
40 percent interestingly austin mcbroom
came in second
the goblin no he's no clown anymore yeah
austin mcbroom surprised me we recently
did a content court on the ace family
oh you didn't and uh i was very
surprised by his antics he is kind of a
dude yeah he's the worst
bella thorne dixie jake paul big head
big head hey that's kind of a compliment
to big head
yeah is it though because no one cares
about him they're probably like who's
big ed
you know i love big ed oh you were
writing with
with uh christian was wrote in with 91
votes that's kind of impressive
oh wow yeah but it's only point three
percent tana was written in and a b
yeah for sure he's like a b was written
in with six votes
we got to find out who those six people
are they're not down interesting
everyone here is a clown goblin oh
everybody on the show voted for av
here i promise that didn't happen he
just like i didn't yo
he's just like yeah i love him i need
more people like a b in my life you just
i love it there's nothing wrong with
that i know i love it
so congratulations james can we can we
please get the steamy for james charles
oh we have one thank you oh gosh james
charles congratulations we'll be
engraving
your name biggest clout goblin
2020. we love you and we appreciate you
and these are two people i'm like just
can't wait till they like disappear off
social media and it will happen look at
ray william johnson on tick tock just
trying to make it i don't know
james is pretty james and jake are both
like
oh no they'll eventually they will like
i mean everyone is like super big at one
point like
comes down like they totally do well
james did came down big time but then he
like got huge on tick tock with like
nobody's gonna care um so i can't wait
like and i and i say that because
they're actually shitty humans like if
they're not you know like
tana i don't think she's like a shitty
human she's just kind of like you know
off-putting i don't think she's like a
crappy human i think well if you think
tana is fine then
then then james charles is fine no like
he's like
evil like he's actually yeah because
like you can't go around like
like the stuff that he does to people is
kind of like gross you know what i mean
and also the fact that you're friends
with like a minor and you think it's
okay like i'm sorry that's manipulation
like you're like power control like
you're kind of gross
and don't say that i said i was good
don't say
you james no i love every other gay
person in this world like i'm like
i i myself am a gaming i like can you be
homophobic for one person
no oh you can't okay i'm just curious
you're like i am homophobic for you
he loves to turn it like that he's an
actual shitty person
stop being friends with minors james
that's disgusting move next
next category thank you james charles
congratulations next category please ian
thank you so much
uh it is biggest douchebag of 2020. now
this this is a good it's a strong
category
for you right i wrote in you you wrote
me in what did i do
i don't know i feel like this would be
the category he could win biggest
douchebag damn i mean it's stiff
competition so
maybe maybe there's other write-ins for
me you didn't no
thank you you're not a douchebag at all
you're actually i was like i'm trying
not you're a cancer
you're a sweetheart oh a cancer see that
you can't
the whole cancer thing just no you're
cancer no no you are
you're i know i am but anyway biggest
douchebag 2020 let's take a look at the
nominees shall we
biggest douchebag of 2020.
mike mashlach he's wearing a dress
he's wearing a dress wearing a dress
doing whippets
what what the [ __ ] were they thinking
there's no one on the show who's more
relatable than me people relate to my
[ __ ] all the time
stuff ethan you are a piece of
[ __ ] garbage garbage everybody tweet
at
[ __ ] h3h3 death to all jews
oh james charles pretty epic can we
steal these designs from teddy fresh
no you are in no position to be talking
about me and my career so i highly
recommend that you stop starting fights
with people that are half your age
jefferson
obviously the entire eye you're about to
see is
filmed out of focus yaya is not a thing
okay
just being stopped trying to make yay
just so jack knows
trisha insisted that we include that and
i thought
well i love jack and
i hope nobody voted for him i wanted to
take shane off one of these categories
i'm like the only way i'm going to like
be okay with like promoting this show is
if we include jack's films in the
biggest douchebag of the year
so let's see maybe he won wouldn't that
be epic
jack is literally the nicest person he's
literally acts like he doesn't know why
you
know
so ridiculous jack is so nice
he's literally unproblematic jack's film
is the most unproblematic person on the
internet he also thinks he's like the
smartest man in the world like oh my god
yeah like okay his alexander hamilton
video i was like he thought he was so
brilliant like when people start copying
can you just give the guy a break like
he's not problematic why do you gotta
hate because he thought he was the first
person to come up with that accidental
hamilton thing i'm like everyone he
didn't
say or think anything he just made a
video oh my god
all right biggest douchebag of 2020. for
me
i mean keemstar wins every year from
based on oh my spit
but there's like james charles is good
and
all jews i don't think that's even like
a joke you can make really
no i don't think so at all but i'm over
the edge for the biggest douchebag
although mike personally has oh might
yeah yeah no mike is
my i wouldn't be mad if mike won he's
like he's very douchey i mean he's nice
he's a nice guy he's very douchey so
uh i'm gonna go with jack's films oh my
god
all right let's get a drum roll biggest
douchebag of 2020.
here we go and the winner
goes
[Music]
keemstar wow
with a resounding the biggest
margin win by far with 56 percent
congratulations to keemstar biggest
douche bag of 2020 incredible
yeah okay i agree james charles in
second with 21
jeffrey starr mike actually didn't even
show
like mike that's cool 4.3 jack's film
actually got 1.3
i love jake paul jack swims is douchier
than jake paul
oh jake paul was a write-in oh that's a
lot
oh he wasn't nominated am i wrong was he
not happening
i don't believe we had him in oh he
should have yeah he should have been
nominated okay
but i don't think anyone could have
topped keemstar 56 that's the highest
margin we've had in a category
keemstar has done some vile things on
the internet for sure yeah he definitely
is like clear when he's like the king of
the category not been like kicked off
youtube
like for real like with that comment
where he's like oh why didn't you like
kill yourself you know what i mean like
that not to bring up that but like well
trisha
i have wondered that myself that's like
actually like isn't that like and also
and also just saying everybody tweet to
ethan death to all jews
right it's like funny that's like a
super funny joke that's all jews did you
get tweets
i don't check my timeline because it's
full of [ __ ] like that
it seems just a little bit beyond like
hating or trolling
noticeable write-ins dr drew came in
with 12 votes don't worry doctor that's
not that much and dan
why dan drew followed me on twitter
that's night you got 12 votes as well
what i mean that's not a lot that's not
a lot
dan's grown on me i would have said last
year when i first
2019 i would have considered dan douche
bag of the year but 2020 he was killing
it so
how does that make you feel you got 12
votes if you're not upsetting somebody
you're you're not doing something there
you go i like it
well keemstar is doing everything right
in his life so congratulations
oh yeah he probably loves that this is
your steamy
biggest douche bag of 2020 and i'll even
put the percentage you won by
56 percent resounding win on that one
congratulations to keemstar
incredible showing incredible showing
now this is just so much
this is way too much fun this is so much
fun oh my goodness having so much fun
with this
i'm so glad we got all dressed up we're
here we're celebrating 2020 the best
aspects feels like a party ian what's
our next category uh
on the flip side of that we've got
biggest mean girl of 2020.
okay this is a weird category okay i'll
tell you what happened okay we had
douchebag and it was
all guys so i was like well we need to
be and i don't want to say the b
word because it's kind of like
derogatory for women it's like
too mean so i was thinking like okay
mean girl
right but what did but what it really is
his biggest b word
you know what i mean oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
i was like what word because i feel like
i just don't like saying that to females
these days it feels too chauvinistic
you know what i mean how the world is
like that now it's like you can't call
it
but if they're a [ __ ] they're a [ __ ]
no i i agree
but i feel like
i feel like for some reason it just it
cuts deeper against women
probably because they just been [ __ ]
with for so long it holds no merit to me
i throw that word around like
you know what i mean it's kind of like
whatever ever like does anyone else feel
that way i'm a [ __ ] so
i don't want to be a baby about it but i
do i just i don't feel comfortable
you're a baby about it i think you're
becoming the woke
no i i'm not well i'm just i don't like
calling women that word it just feels
bad if they're a bitter [ __ ] i agree
if i called ela [ __ ] she would [ __ ] i
would die
she would murder me did moses call you
[ __ ] i mean that's crossing the line
no he treats me like a queen um i don't
know eely handled it pretty well when i
called her a [ __ ] i didn't mean it no
but you're one
female to female right right right but
do you know what i mean when you say eel
is a [ __ ]
that's way more heavy than saying like
oh dan's a [ __ ] douchebag
it hits harder but i was being a [ __ ]
when i said that you know what i mean
anyway biggest mean girl of 2020. so
let's go ahead and review the nominees
biggest mean girl of 2020
dixie tamilio
oh my god dixie what the hell um so
why did you do that why would shane
dawson the king of
truth on youtube the king of truth
turning against james charles unless
these things he was saying in the truth
it's been a long time [ __ ]
[ __ ] you yeah oh my god look at these
people trisha pages
everyone's against ethan like oh my gosh
i'm always right
it's like ugh you and jacksonville
deserve each other so i can't believe
you're going after jax he's such a sweet
guy
all right trisha oh my god
you definitely i mean are you honored to
be to be included
i'm definitely a mean girl but it comes
from insecurity
i think you're great okay i'm honored um
yeah are you
they're like trisha is an adult
entertainer therefore she is not
credible for this sort i'm like first of
all it's not because i'm an adult
entertainer that i'm not credible
but okay i forget in what context she
she
mentioned the person who countersued her
said like oh they brought my video as
like an evidence against her which i
don't know why they did that but then
tatia's lawyer wrote back and said well
this is an adult entertainer so she is
not credible
yeah no no that is that's what there's
other reasons they could have said i'm
not credible but they're like well
but it literally said adult performer
who's not credible
[Music]
[ __ ] utah team ice queen yeah well
biggest mean girl of 2020 let's get a
drum roll please this is a big one
this i mean stiff competition
i really don't know i feel like there
could be a lot of votes for you but i
feel like the other two are so
deserving of the title the winner is
[Music]
tati westbrook that's good i think it
was me
really i mean i feel like tati
deserves this one with 32 percent
she won resoundingly you weren't second
with 25
but i did make fun of your mom's cooking
called ela the c
word like i think i deserve to be but
again like you said like you
like like you said you don't mean it but
tati is an ice queen
bonafide mean girl i think i'm meaner
than tati this sucks
the people have spoken trisha uh gabby
hannah and third
really close between you and gabby
actually gaby is not
mean she just needs help and dixie was
17
i mean dixie's pretty mean when i see
those clips i'm kind of like yeah she's
pretty mean
but tati i mean god bless tati or like
hello to tati this year
tati congratulations you are the meanest
girl of 2020 right
out of your lawsuit keep me up don't
stick my
name out of your mouth [ __ ] that's the
quote of 2020.
don't talk about me keep my name out of
your mouth so much fun
ian what's our next category uh moving
along our next one is worst influencer
song
oh oh wait i just realized does trisha
have any on there
no no oh wow wow okay i thought
i just realized that trisha should be on
there at least once
um i suggested we eliminate everyone but
dixie because i think the only one who
has a [ __ ]
trisha wanted to it all to be dixie
songs
and no one else no one else deserves it
it's literally just well let's have a
look at the nominees and we can uh think
about it
worst influencer song
[Music]
be happy dixie dimigo
one day one day i was really really
really really sad
dixie damilia her new
her new firebox
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
you know it's crazy that dixie became so
famous just by being charlie's sister
i mean that's clown goblin [ __ ] oh
that's true oh i get it yeah
she's totally yeah she's literally
that's it no she's like one day
one day all right oh poor drum roll
please
who do you think is gonna win i think
dixie i mean obviously by the way
tristan nominated
at first it was just three dixie songs
and we're like we should add somebody
else
because that was the winner is
by overwhelming majority
for one day with 42 it's probably the
only award she'll ever win in her life
so
dixie one day one day
i was really really really really sad
not today she's the winner today second
place was jake paul freschetta london
and third place once again dixie be
happy
oh and uh dixie roommates people like
that one apparently only four percent
but one day this is a huge so
congratulations dixie
congrats you are your son you are an
award-winning artist
that's amazing yeah i mean that's
amazing because like let's face it a
year she's not going to be anywhere so
she'll be like oh at least i want to see
me
here's a nice steamy for you dixie one
day
congratulations one day this is so
exciting maybe you should get on some
antidepressants because your songs are
be happy and one day she's
i'm just didn't they work for you you're
thriving
you don't know anything about her her
songs are called she wants to be happy
she's really really sad i think she's
crying for help to have someone guide
her in the right way
i'm not a doctor i'm just saying maybe
check it out maybe let's say go
ghost talk to a psychiatrist and see if
antidepressants are right for you
that's so true right don't take my
advice they weren't right for me but
maybe they'll be right for her
she seems like she has more together
than me so 20 milligrams of lexapro set
me straight
hell yeah i like prozac although i did
nevermind prozac nash i ran a car into a
tree on prozac
oh my god was that the prozac or you
though it's hard to know that was the
prozac for real
it was never had that that's kind of
awesome to be like it was the lexus pro
it was the prozac i swear
[Laughter]
what's our next category please ian it's
uh most brutal cancellation
okay this is a category i was not happy
about but i like that you changed the
title
so at first excuse me
i'm trying to spread covet everywhere no
i'm kidding i don't have coffee
this is my cough how about that let's
normally stretch twice that wasn't a
tourette's tape oh
what is that what was it i was just
coughing
that's not coughing that's like okay
yeah exactly it's
meant to be ridiculous i'll cut it off
to tourette's it's kind of like your
prozac like it was the tourettes
officer was the tourettes i love having
a friend with tourette's because now i
can like have a soapbox or something
like normalized tourettes
oh thank you i co-hosted you could sell
box for my ass
i'm gonna be like all my tic tacs will
be about you should do that all your
tickets should be about
having tourette's and like you know
mine's all about being a fat girl you
should be like oh here's me
you want my entire identity to revolve
around having tourette's that's what you
got to do
i've been fine so far social media you
got to like go for a thing that people
feel sorry for you for
most people don't know i have it they
just think i'm a weirdo and i'm happy
with that
because i don't want my whole existence
to be defined by the guy with dourettes
but you could help so many people with
tourette's i think people who have
tourettes who watch me know that i have
tourette's
i didn't know that i know people you
don't have tourette's
what do you want me to say good job
tourette people of the world with
tourette's
hear me now yeah i will be your
spokesperson
yeah they're fine do you have hebrew in
your jacket
is that rented by israeli it's like a
hebrew in your in your coat
in your neck back of your neck
oh maybe she's upside down yeah okay
just kidding so
this was originally called best
cancellation but that's not what it is
it's not
we're not passing a judgment value on if
this person deserved to be cancelled or
not
we're just saying it was like the most
complete
shocking brutal cancellation it was a
harsh cancelling it was just like
wow that was the big cancellation of the
year right because we do also have jenna
in this category who's very well liked
no one thought she deserved to be
beautiful but got a brutal cancellation
well she kind of canceled herself
she did cancellers and then julian
canceled her even more he's like stop
talking about
jenna's cancellation video and i was
like you're just canceling her more like
oh really
people were pissed that we nominated her
everyone's like this is insensitive
julian hates when people talk about
jenna's cancellation oh well what i mean
it's the internet but i love first of
all let me just say i love
jenna and julia i think they're great
people and i and i i've always admired
uh jenna marbles yeah so again this
isn't a
value pass on on on them it's just
we're we're acknowledging the categories
so with that being said dan
roll it most brutal
cancellation tatty westbrook
bye-bye bye chris delia
ouch ouch ouch family
they didn't know yeah they're still
wrong lopez now he's still right now
jenna marbles or jenna yeah we love her
shane
so i mean that wow that was a brutal one
i mean
for me it's definitely thank you it's
definitely between if you want to talk
about brutal cancellations yeah
shane and chris were the biggest
they got stomped on the hardest this
year yeah like both of them are just
gone
yeah and i don't know chris but he
seemed like a nice guy and all his
friends turned against i loved chris
like at least jane how like i stood by
him like his friends like he didn't lose
you know what i mean like
so this thing with shane is different in
my opinion because with shane it's not
like he
necessarily did anything yeah it's all
like bad jokes from a long time ago
right whereas chris is like actively
doing slimy stuff
tony lopez actually admits like sexting
15 year old how is he actually not
canceled like it's insane to me
so yeah like and shane's been cancelled
this multiple times like the the
the fact that like the smiths jumped in
on it like oh yeah 15 years later
buried his ass it's like oh calm down
jada pinkett like her daughter was
posing topless at 13 with her 21 year
old boyfriend
so maybe what focus on that yeah there's
there's like a topless photo of will
smith at 13 years old
with her 21 year old boyfriend moises
aries or whatever
who's 21 year old boyfriend um willow
smiths
was 13 dating a 21 year old actor named
moises
look it up from the district look that
up right now somebody fact right now
right now i can't put that out there
without knowing back jacket it's not
just like i would never put
it out there is that just like rape
look that up look it up somebody looking
it up and like
don't like i mean the thing is is like
that's what you should be worrying about
you know what i mean like
wait i gotta know if that's true or not
because
yeah i couldn't say it if it's not a 13
year old was dating a 21 year old
i mean they say we're friends but she's
topless in bed with this guy
that is insanely disturbing
moises our aries yep what
he was a disney channel star and he was
like 20 21 at the time of the photos and
she was 13.
they introduced him as a family friend
though but
why was he in bed with her and she was
topless
how does that isn't that child
pornography how's that out it's well she
he was like covering her she was
covering herself or something but
it's disgusting focus on that there it
is right there
photo look baby showing you let me see
this
oh this is weird
wait why is this photo out was this part
of a shoot
yeah they posted it yeah this was a
while ago but yeah
[Music]
they're in bed this was after shane's
joke this was like 20 so like
what exactly
oh my god this was shared on social
media
weird i am blown away by this
also the smith family kind of has
nowhere to talk they are so [ __ ] up
oh and on the did you watch the red
table with olivia jade and they were
talking about how like she has all this
privilege white privilege
okay let's talk about rich people
privilege your daughter has that too
yeah they'd be like
oh my gosh like you have this like this
white privilege but you also have rich
privilege your
your parents are famous that's why you
can get away with that photo and that's
why like it's
i mean smith privilege is is as powerful
as anything on this point the most
powerful thing
so don't even i mean it's uh i have so
many but that whole red table
show is like ruining their life like
she's so she's a clown goblin
a clown goblin for a shirt because she's
like airing all their dirty laundry for
views on facebook and it's like and
that's like she goes oh i had an affair
with will with this guy and will smith
is out there like dude
i'm trying to live my [ __ ] life you
know what i mean ladies leave me
where did you see the one where she's
like oh let's debate on if it's okay
that white people adopt black babies i'm
like
why would that would you rather the
black baby not have a family that's
literally
they had the girl from sex in the city
who adopted an african-american baby and
they had her on and they were being like
is this is this weird that like white
people
i mean it's always divided it's always
divided like it's it's crazy how
dare you want to love a family a baby
that has no family
and she's like and everybody sees color
it's like some people just want a baby
some people are just infertile like well
the thing is some people just i don't
know if they specifically ask for a
black baby but their weight it takes a
while until you have a baby ready for
a family that wants to adopt a newborn
baby yeah so it might be black it might
be white it might be asian
a baby to take care of in love like it's
crazy well i haven't seen that but i
agree with your
assessment uh what the facts presented
anyways with that being said
drum roll please this is a huge hotly
uh anticipated category most brutal
cancellation guys come on
most brutal cancellation of 2020
goes to with a huge margin
shane dawson actually the biggest margin
good honestly because people recognize
that it's brutal
57 and i have to say be i think it was
the fact that
shane had such an explosive year of
course
and then such an explosive cancellation
yeah because he was so at the height of
his
you know i like i i you know i i like
shane i feel bad
because it's like again like i said
crystal lee was actively doing scummy
things
right shane there was a lot of like
tasteless gags from before i met him all
those jokes were like before i even met
him there's not one video where he's
making those jokes with me i met him in
2011. you know what i mean so
he was hmm yeah and and but the fact
that jenna's number two this is great
because
they're recognizing people that was
brutal it was like unjustified
is what i'm thinking because she got
canceled too for making like asians
because like
i feel like people are interpreting this
as un unjustified because crystalia only
has ten percent
tati right like they think they don't
but anyway almost 60 percent for shane
so congratulations to shane i think
for most brutal cancellation 20. well
deserved yeah people want him back and
he will be can we get a uh
she could come back at any time people
would love him thank you
shane congratulations can we set that
aside
i'll go to him oh yeah please well
should we engrave it first
are you gonna actually engrave it are we
gonna engrave these it's just plastic
can you engrave it
we can yeah we can get a little knife
and yeah i think we should
rave it for everyone and put it up you
can deliver it to him maybe he can do an
acceptance speech for us yeah for sure a
little video
congratulations brutalist cancellation
this is a pro shane anti-james charles
podcast
we love that we stand there uh the next
category is worst apology
worst youtuber apology i'm so excited
for this one i am the master
at calling out bad apology videos no one
is sincere these days you know it was
sincere i'm sincere when i mess up only
you are sincere
only me all the other ones are fake so
let's go
let's see it dan west
apology a long overdue
apology mongoose
a message jenna marbles
admitting when i'm wrong doctor [ __ ] you
doctor mike
breaking my silence by the way that
title is so dramatic doing what's right
jeffree star doing all these titles we
went to therapy
i really did oh god all those
were horrible vegas youtuber worst
youtuber apologies so we are rating
the insincere worst one out there what
do you what
are you thinking well she never really
apologized so i would have to give it to
tati
for not apologizing in her apology video
also the title
breaking my silence that's what people
say after they've gotten like assaulted
like
that you know the r word like that's so
what happened it's like you're coming
out against all the odds
breaking my silence like crazy
all right i actually i don't know who's
gonna be in here but let's get a drum
roll for worst youtuber apology
2020 who is it gonna be
the winner is by a very very close
margin
down to the wire whoa jeffrey starr
worst youtube apology wow
jeffrey oh i gotta say jeffrey won with
26.3
tati and second place with 26.1 percent
a real
nail-biter tana close the third 21 ace
family dr mike
jenna with jenna marbles if you're
watching you got point six percent which
is i think you should have been at zero
right crazy well i think it was
jeffrey's
setting in sincere the setting
in his 15 million mansion just like let
me uh
so if we can do you think we can get
this to jeffrey worst
youtube apology 2020. i would like to
make amends with jeffrey this year he's
so what better way than to hand deliver
this steaming pile of poop award
um yeah we can try that excellent i feel
like i might have been a little harsh on
jeffrey last year like i think he was i
still think he's a weirdo yeah but
he's like a weird goblin man are you
going by the looks or you like his
everything um he's really nice though he
is like nice
why'd you do a flip-flop on him well he
i had he had a mean girl moment where he
was like making fun of my weight and
skin
and stuff behind my back but but why are
you do you think he
because like he has a lot of leverage
are you interested in clout
no jeffrey claw i cuz he does have clown
no no i think it's just more like i know
his like he comes from like the similar
like sex work i did like he was
on craigslist like i mean he talked
about in the shane documentary like
[ __ ] dick on craigslist really how
much did he charge do you know
because you were only five i wonder if
he charged you can't really charge less
than five for a blowy
uh you could do it for drugs but he
doesn't do drugs so probably not drugs
so it's more valuable than five
probably i well you get the five and the
drugs like
it was awesome yeah but um yeah i think
he's just like really broken and secure
like he's always on the defense
i see he said he went to therapy this
year so hopefully that helped because it
helped me like if you're always on the
defense like i was always on the defense
for so long like
it's just more because you're like
broken and you don't want to get hurt
okay so a little empathy here from 2021
trisha we like that
net we have two categories i would like
to try your mom's cooking again in 2021
because
my mom's over you oh she hates me my mom
canceled you
[ __ ] really what if she like okay she's
a new person ah my mom's fine she
doesn't hold up
congrats and she'd say congratulations a
text instead of congratulations she did
yeah she was happy for you she's over it
but she was really mad it was funny you
know when i think about it i'm like
because my mom my mom yeah my mom
doesn't really ever get like that and
she's like i hate her
she's complained about my cooking maybe
we'll just work
towards that yeah let's not yeah we want
russian to pass over with her but it's
okay
that's okay um next category please uh
next category is biggest reverse card
oh this so this is kind of a complex one
to explain but
the biggest uno reverse card what's this
i forget
is when somebody did a flip-flop a 180
or like they
they made some some big statement and
then walked it back
yes okay so best creator uno reverse
card
let's see the uh the nominees please dan
thank you
biggest reverse card dr drew
down place covid gets covered
that you're more likely to die of
influenza so go ahead get your flu shots
doesn't hurt anybody that should be the
headline way less serious than influenza
oh yeah
this corona thing doesn't worry me it is
at all it is a press
induced panic i am angry about it it is
the flu
he is battling covid19
from his bedroom and i'm telling you
what we know how to treat it now
but it really requires careful
management by physicians westbrook
forms james charles alliance james
charles came to me
apologized to each other forgave each
other and agreed to wait patiently until
it was safe for me to share my story
james charles has repeatedly said that
he wanted to be beside me for this video
mike castafa puts adopted son back up
for adoption
youtube star micah stauffer is opening
up about her controversial decision to
re-home her adopted son
huxley when they brought him home she
said he was profoundly developmentally
delayed
he was diagnosed with autism spectrum
disorder
level three now micah writes that she's
praying that huxley only has the best
future in the entire world
[Music]
i think and i correct me if i'm wrong
you guys might be more but she actually
tried
she wanted to adopt someone that had
yeah she said it in a video
specifically especially she wanted a
special needs baby
and she's like this is too much for me
it's it's honestly so
bad so tragic that it's hard to even
think about
but i'm sure that the the kid probably
is in a better home i hope
because he was re-adopted so hard
to adopt a child like look there's no
way i'll ever get a child like they
they're so strict at like
as far as like if you're married your
mental illness like stuff you do online
like all that stuff is so hard to adopt
a baby so like
you adopted this baby and you like got
him you like he's
legally yours use them as content no i
know and then you're gonna give them
back they you they put him in every
video they made a whole thing about him
and um apparently she did again again
correctly i might be speaking that term
but
they didn't think they could get
pregnant and then when she got pregnant
is when she
put him back up but i i cut don't quote
me on that do you guys know
if that nobody knows okay so oh and so i
may be speaking at it
children are so loving and so i mean all
children are amazing but like
especially like autism like and down
children too they're so
have so much like love and like pure in
it like it's crazy to me that's
crazy to me like those people like want
to be loved like more than anything like
it's like it's great and they have so
much love to give aside from wanting to
be loved like they'll give you so much
love like it's insane like she's
obviously never been around children
with like autism like it's so
so sad to me like like when i looked at
adopting like i thought i i was like her
too i was like i want to adopt like a
special needs baby because they have
like
the number one thing is everyone's like
they have so much like love to give and
like that's why people want babies and
all that stuff like that and take care
of them but ah
i will say i hate i feel a little bad
for dr drew
i see that all the covid denial stuff
was in like
february march
i had to you know i feel bad doctor drew
we do love you
but i mean he's kind of like a little
bit of a troll though i think he kind of
like plays up a little bit
he went on the whole fox news tour and
everything yeah
i like him i think we're very similar i
mean dr drew you want to [ __ ] dr drew
we're both co-dependent too he followed
me on twitter after the last episode
what do you think that means
i think it means he wants to [ __ ] you
clearly dr drew is a sexy man he's very
attractive
he gets me i think he gets me
god he gets i love dr drew can we have a
monika you're like no
no i love dr joe too it's great uh
content
um good thing we didn't have him in
person that episode because i wanted him
he would have asked
he wanted to show up in person he wanted
him
he's like i want to come do it in person
i was like you bro i seen you on fox
news let's keep you at
arm's length talking about cove it isn't
[ __ ]
real and [ __ ] okay so drum roll
we are at we are out of envelopes people
we ran out of envelopes
this one is like they all deserve the
award honestly biggest uno reverse card
[Music]
the adoption obviously i mean i can't we
can't even applaud that
micah staff staffer
she might be the worst of all these
awards like that's
you're giving an actual human being back
that's either has autism
like there's actually so doctor you'd be
happy to know you only got
five percent of the votes tati and james
was in close second with
90 34 and this was actually a really
good write-in which i wish was on there
ethan and trisha making a podcast
together
30 points which let's be honest but i
don't think it's better than giving your
adopted child back
i don't think it's quite the same but
that's kind of as
reverse card as it gets so i'm not sure
they're gonna want this award
i'm pretty sure that they will not want
this award
they deserve the worst of the worst of
2020 like they deserve all these awards
we just sent it to them i don't want to
assume too much about them because it's
such a horrible
tragic situation that i i can't even
i can't even put my head in that space i
just
all i say is that this award is for you
best uno reverso card
2020 for returning your adopted son so
oh congratulations like that made me
sick
it was so fun and then like that award
is kind of like made me like not well we
have our biggest award
after is next we actually ran out of
trophies so we still have a couple more
oh
oh we ran out of trophies too what is
this shoestring [ __ ]
back what i said about the h3 crew i
thought they had their [ __ ] together
we have four more awards okay what's the
next category the next one is spiciest
drama
spiciness that sounds great let's take a
look
someone might be able to reuse a trophy
teddy fresh first james charles
i am wearing the brand new sisters
apparel color block collection which
will be launching
next week like this [ __ ]
hi sisters
i'm gonna break this down into three
parts so the first part we'll cover when
we met and early problematic behavior
the second part which gets much worse
of her trashing and using james charles
and jeffree star
microaggressions towards the lgbtq plus
community and racist behavior
and the third part which disturbs me the
most will bring us to the moment that
pushed me over
for your doctorate which is the reason
why i'm making this video h3h3
keemstar i am but one man
probably not even the most hated man in
keemstar's life
and you've seen the length he's gone to
harass me
good luck ethan because you're gonna
[ __ ] need it h3h3
death to all jews david delbricks
by david dover that's me you take your
camera on your phone nobody else cares
and then you scan it because it's a qr
code and look now it'll load your prize
and you're going to 100
win because you're gonna win anywhere
from 25 cents to a hundred thousand
dollars
according to the data from the puzzle's
own website 99.3 percent of people who
buy this puzzle will get a negative
return in that their
dies will be under the initial thirty
dollars spent filled
i
i have a lot to say about it jeffree
star first contacted me early in his
youtube career wanting to meet
shut up i learned being friends with
jeffree star was like being friends with
the lion
she literally only gets attention but he
was
always really kind to me coming out
example
breaking the silence look how serious
she is too
there are people dying snail fiasco
yeah the snail's not really up there but
it's a good category
spiciest drama wow there's so much oh
you and um you and keem went at it yeah
that was a pretty big one
i have to say it was pretty monumental
compared to everything else on that list
but let me think
i'm gonna go with david dobrik's puzzle
scheme okay yeah so so when you put that
i was like what
everybody loves david but when i looked
into it i will say i was like this
is super super shady he's a rich white
straight privilege at its finest like
literally nothing he does
this one straight up like
wait it's not a scam but it's like it's
gambling he has
he so he goes he goes he goes buy this
puzzle build it there's a qr code
and then you can win money and it's cost
30 bucks and he says everybody wins
which is true but the puzzle costs 30
and usually most people win 25 cents
yeah
and so he's literally just selling a
lottery ticket that you have to put
together
and then it sounds illegal i don't know
how he got away with that they're there
and you have to be you have to be 18
years old to buy a lottery ticket you
don't have to be 18 to buy this [ __ ]
qr
he sent out puzzles to his friends so
everyone in the vlog squad were putting
together puzzles so they could have the
chance to 100 thousand dollars
which like you're not supposed to like
anyways then it's like one person gives
a hundred thousand dollars
i i listen to their podcast or something
like that he's made over like three
million dollars with this puzzle
oh yeah i mean you didn't have to sell
that many
and it's a qr code that to me that to me
legitimately should be investigated that
that seems illegal
it seems super shady and illegal he's
he's put together
a lottery and people who are buying
these are not 18 years old
i wonder if he has a loophole because
he's like daca he's not like legal here
so you know he can do that you think
daca people who just come here and [ __ ]
up the whole
no no i i don't know if he had
i'm sure he consulted lawyers he's
pretty big time but to me
this seems like it has to be illegal and
i don't think it's been investigated
because
you can't just put together your own lot
lotteries are tightly regulated
and they're mostly run by states to
raise money for schools and [ __ ]
and so for him to put together a lottery
and then sell it to people who are under
18
seems super [ __ ] illegal yeah and i i
think that
if it hasn't been investigated i think
it should that's because
lotteries are lotteries are an important
source of funds
raising for states each state has its
own lottery
right and people buy buy into it and the
majority
or like half of the money goes to
charity work
because it's a vice so the state goes
okay well let's at least turn it into
something good right
we'll be raising money for schools and
[ __ ] but david dobrik is like no i'm
gonna
i'm gonna that's all for me and he
literally also a hundred thousand i mean
step it up when you make three million
dollars you're gonna get a hundred
thousand like at least give that to like
10 people or something like it's so
i was shocked when i learned that i was
not cool with this i'm not
okay with this this is so shady that's
what i'm saying like people i'm the
worst person to be this like voice for
this but like because i'm the only one
who like sees it because
people are just like so blinded like oh
he gives people money and like cars and
it's like but that doesn't mean there's
a reason he's giving people money
he's making a [ __ ] load of money it's
it's a scam
and i'm sorry you're you're giving it to
your friends he gifted like well
i don't see anything wrong with that
because like rigging you know knowing
the person like
you're right there's rules to
sweepstakes and lottery you can't know
the people
this is all lotteries are tightly
regulated because it's so prone to
criminal uh manipulation
yeah so i don't know like the dude i am
so
not okay with this and it's like you can
go out and make a million bucks if you
don't give a [ __ ] about anything
and like selling gambling lotteries to
kids without any regulations is an easy
[ __ ] way to make a million dollars
straight up scamming i see these people
on tick tock too they're like if you
follow me on tick tock like i'll give
like the person a thousand dollars but
like you have to like
buy this i'm like that you can you
literally can't do that people are
getting away with it there's so many
tick tockers like i said all the time
like well you know the fda is uh
or not the fta the the uh
the fcc is is starting to clamp down a
lot on creators because they're doing
all this crazy [ __ ]
and it's like super unregulated if you
have to purchase to win something like
i think that's illegal i don't think you
should have you need right
yeah so you need to be able to get it
for free if it's a sweepstake but this
is a lottery and i don't know i'm sure
the laws are very complicated
i have to assume he consulted a lawyer
but whoever it was
i want this investigated i really do
this is not okay
it's not okay it's really disturbing
it's like
and he's not too nice not to bring up
the dog but it's not it's just a puzzle
of a qr code it doesn't have any
entertainment value it's literally just
putting together a lottery
hoping to win a hundred thousand from
david over i can't get over it when he's
made
three million dollars off of you he
probably made a lot more than that oh
i'm sure
because it's 30 bucks i mean he could he
easily sold it half a million dollars in
merch
on twitch he makes like like what
happened like he's like don't
don't do this yeah he's like he quit
youtube and he's just strictly on twitch
now he hasn't made a vlog since march of
last year what did he do on twitch
i think gaming really yeah i don't know
oh my god but be careful investigate
david dobrik
like you're also not allowed to leave
this i like david
i i like david i met him i think he's a
sweet guy i'm surprised he did this
and i'm surprised he's lost me guys this
is what i've been saying he's fraudulent
from the start
no i don't know but i'm surprised people
around him didn't
tell him not to do this this is very
disturbing but nobody gave him any [ __ ]
for it so apparently
nobody gives a [ __ ] yeah i didn't even
know about it he if i knew about this i
would have called him
paul like applauded him he's like great
idea man yeah it's a great idea to make
money if you don't give a [ __ ] about
anything
if you're a total psychopath unless
you're like shitty merch you're getting
like a sweatshirt or something it's like
it's like saying hey i made a website i
made a website where
if you give me money i'll give you a one
percent chance of giving you your money
back or more
and they're like great idea
oh my god well i'm glad you cost oh no
big cosine thank you huge cosine thank
you can that be a great idea dude
great idea he's oh my god i'm so
i'm actually upset about this
investigate david dobrik
and logan paul [ __ ] it anyway the winner
is
drum roll spiciest drama oh
oh thank god it's not me tati vs jeffrey
oh i wish you would have won i agree
tati vs jeffrey
you guys were the spiciest drama that
was right before [ __ ] hit the fan like
the black lives matter and people are
getting canceled freaking racists like
you and keem were like
the height of the drama the summer
before like yeah but
the the scope of the tati videos she
gets so many views on her drama videos
you know
yeah i'm jealous i wish i could be that
like relevant
well you don't want to be relevant in
the way she is because nobody watches
any of her others she's getting sued
all right and her business partner's
like she's a scammer yeah her life is
like ruined kind of right now but
that's why it's better to be middle of
the ground you know just don't do any
actual scams she's getting
she's getting sued for for
like defrauding her business partner
yeah maybe just don't do that
yeah so anyway tati vs jeffrey wins with
34
james versus teddy fresh actually in
second place with 32
very close h levers came 26
and then everything else was really low
david dobreck 2.4 nobody cares
the snails point six glam and gold is
gonna care david
watch it there was a huge write-in ethan
versus tricia i guess that's true we
should have included that
wait for what what one well we were all
like everything
[Laughter]
um but i don't think it would top so
congratulations jeffrey
and tati i think you've already both won
an award so don't be greedy
we'll we'll etch in to win ian are you
still with your girlfriend
yes exactly bachelor season three
bachelor h3 bachelor has resulted in
a long-term relationship and an
engagement
wow that's insane i mean our track
record compared to the real bachelor is
like
insane like the real bachelor's track
record is like five percent
you need to do another one i think so i
just i need to find a good candidate
it's hard to find the right your biggest
like flex is like finding
me someone that like wanted to marry me
like that never would have been possible
ever nobody's ever wanted to marry me or
even have a long term or claim me as a
girlfriend like this is insane
i agree i mean it's unbelievable we make
dreams come true like he actually like
tries to get me pregnant i don't like
trick him or anything like it's insane
yeah i wouldn't recommend tricking dudes
i think i did in the past i don't
recommend it
really what did you do i think i'm like
yeah i'm a birth control oh that's so
[ __ ] nice it's [ __ ] up but girls do
it i'm just telling people out there
that's like illegal i feel like it's not
it's not it should be it should be
that's a terrible crime if a girl tells
you on birth control just don't believe
her especially if you have money like
just don't believe her
um you better put those pills in her
mouth and watch her swallow them
no for real because you know the biggest
one i used to tell people is like yeah i
got the shot i'm good for like three
years
so i was only ever with women who were
on birth control when people were like i
do not want to have a baby with that man
you know what i mean yeah i was like
broke not going anywhere i was like
she's on birthday
yeah no one's gonna try and trick you
back then dude i can't believe you did
that that's super scummy
oh i i agree i mean i've done like waste
gummier things in the past what did you
do with
oh my god so many people you want to
have babies with them like
rich like like famous people that i
slept with i definitely was like trying
to like you're like
i just want that that child support oh
yeah for sure
i thought that was my way to go i
applaud your honesty but holy [ __ ]
that's messed up it's so messed up and
like it definitely didn't work it just
gave me like chlamydia which it made me
infertile so joke's on me like you know
what i mean like it was bad
it backfired back like sometime yeah
i was trying to okay you think a lot of
girls do that oh my god
the guy i was trying to have a baby with
like impregnated two different people
and stuff like
this my ticket too you know like let me
out on it didn't work for me but
oh my god yeah
so i'm talking sobering moment oh no i
know
guys are surprised like oh [ __ ] she's on
birth what
i have a friend who's a very famous
director he's not my friend he's like a
person i know he was a
very famous director he got a porn and i
won't say this i can't say that sorry
let me take this keep going no rewind
no it's not out there it is now
everyone literally people who know
already figured out what you were saying
no they don't okay anyways just don't be
surprised like especially if you have
money and even if you don't have money
like they're like
i guess if i was dating and wealthy or
famous or whatever then
maybe i'd be more pronounced but i never
even thought about it before it's a
thing
so many girls do and i know somebody's
horrifying are you kidding me look at
dwayne wade he has like nine baby mamas
like
dude yeah but you at that point you put
on the condom dumb [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying did you ever poke
a hole in a condom or anything like that
no everybody's been never used condoms
so i never was like worried about it
really
people are so quick to just be like not
inside you
god this world is crazy it's pretty
crazy moses did not fall for my tricks
though he did not fall for my tricks i i
think one time he asked me i think i
might when i was on like high or
something i was like yes i have a shot
but he still pulled out he's like i
don't trust this [ __ ] i don't even
trust pull out
like pulling out i learned in sex ed
falling out to only 50
effective is that true yeah
yeah pulling out it's like you're in raw
there's preaches and everything
i yeah
i wouldn't trust to pull out with
someone if i didn't want to get pregnant
i ain't pulling out a [ __ ] right that
yeah for sure
but also there's a chance that you don't
pull out in time because you have to
like
because like you know it's not you can't
always get a perfect pull out a perfect
dismount
you know what i mean sometimes it's a
partial dismount right right
it's just not safe yeah it's not a safe
also like stds and stuff like that
i don't want stds as much as i don't
want a child with somebody i don't like
right right and then you're stuck look
at david spade like i don't know him
personally i don't know the story
but he got this playmate pregnant and
she lives in like minnesota now and she
has a baller s house because he has to
pay child support maybe like twice a
year
you don't know him but that's what i
wrote kids are amazing though hopefully
you're like i'm so even though i nutted
in your mom and i think she's a
[ __ ] weirdo and i wish i never had to
see her more than once yeah i love you
people do come around the guy i was
talking about that i don't really know
personally he's not really that close of
a friend he did come around and like
he at first didn't want anything to do
with the child and now he i think has a
relationship with the child so
i think over time remember the child's
fault that you were an idiot but then
sometimes they don't come around like
you know stories too
dad that just does not want anything to
do with the kid and that's right that's
not okay
not okay yeah and don't do that honestly
well guys
i learned a lot here today everybody be
careful out there yeah no
no but for real like how are guys still
so stupid zach's gonna get a girl
pregnant for sure
everybody here's taken that's good i
like that but zach is gonna get like
he's with a girl he's with an adult i
think he moved on he's
oh really yeah wait wasn't what they're
like actually traveling salesman
zack's the worst no he's not he's the
worst he was the ultimate narcissist so
but he wasn't exploiting you were wait
he was not an exploitative narcissist he
was like a self-confident narcissist
anyway let's continue how ironic we have
a new
what's our next category uh it's biggest
fake friendship
biggest fake friendship us
yeah we were on there oh we are i don't
think we're fake though we're really
good at
i don't think so but sometimes you get
the vibe that you think so yeah you know
what i think it is in comparison to like
when you do trick someone into having a
baby with you and
eventually they come around and it
becomes a family that's what happened
here yeah
maybe you know we kind of like okay
we'll fake it or whatever and then like
that was never my intention to come out
here and fake anything just to be can i
just say i
dated moses just to rub it in your guy's
face and now we're freaking engaged and
bought a house though well i'm glad you
said that which explains why there was
so much friction
that was early on that was early on
stupid you
dated moses to rub in my face oh i was
so excited to come back
backfired on who on your plans i guess
not i know i was gonna be like i [ __ ]
your brother
stupid i mean i still can say that
on the daily gross stop nut inside
stop but don't have to trick him so you
should applaud me for that
all right play the video for christ's
sake biggest
fake friendship the vlog squad
that one's probably really good i wonder
how many episodes we
we make before before this whole thing
is burned to the ground
james charles and literally anyone
else i've been texting back and forth
hanging out a few times behind the
scenes as well
behind the scenes so let me think here
that's a small category people are not
going to vote for the vlog squad because
they love them they're white
i don't know that that fact you're
jewish or you're like our minority in
this so we
kind of have a i think people are going
to vote for us and then what was the
other one james charles and
literally anyone that one's might win
too i mean that's the truest probably
i don't think we have a fake friendship
but people are going to vote for us for
the meme i think
it started i think we started that that
way and i never faked anything trisha
there was never any collusion about
faking liking each other weird [ __ ]
i faked a little bit at the beginning
that's fine i'm just saying i didn't
okay
drum roll biggest fake friendship goes
to wow with a resounding
this is the biggest margin by far at
72.9 percent james and literally
anyone else and trisha i'm so flattered
that we came in last place with 12.5
percent
oh people know that that really
surprised me and then vlog squad even
beat us out
at 13.7 but james really
absolutely smashed this category i
actually
thank you guys for voting us last i'm
actually touched by that
they can see past it they're like that's
some love that's really nice thank you
and we need an award we need here this
one's for er i'm going to steal one from
some
okay we should keep ours james we have
two awards for you
i have one [ __ ] the biggest um
the fakest friend of 2020 he so is
everyone's his best friend
we are best friends behind the scenes
until they lose clout right
james we love you this is an anti-james
charles podcast all the way
that should just be the name of our
podcast okay and then we have
we've got two more two more so the next
one is uh account
ban of the year oh this one is really
good i'm ready for this one i think this
is my win
i don't know you're up against really
stiff competition this sucks this sucks
though cause like when you don't win
that just means like you're not relevant
like
no one cares about the vlog squad
david's relevant you lost your instagram
somebody some people lost like their
entire livelihood
right instagram was kind of like
flailing it's not that big of a deal and
i was at 2.2 million for four years so i
was shadow band anyways
right because you're posting like your
titties did you help me get by the way
my background
well you said they were they're going to
bring it back in 30 days someone told me
today because i had someone else help me
that has a connection there and they
said it was permanently disabled just
deleted
can you don't you have connections i
thought you had connections well you
said they'd be back in 30 days so i was
like okay they're not going to reverse
that but i can send an email
but if they ban i think they're they're
clamping down hard and people who
promote only fans
but i've been promoting only fans you
know what it was i promoted adam and eve
but i didn't know that was like the
because i stopped promoting only fans
they gave me warnings i was like you
know let me stop it on instagram and so
i stopped
and then the adam and eve i guess you
can't just anything sex related you
can't promote i'll email them but i
think you're [ __ ]
because like there's people like belle
delphine could never got hers back well
hers was like really raunchy like mine's
not
raunchy anymore like i literally did the
lingerie of adam and eve and i was like
[ __ ]
but i made sure my nipples were kind of
like i'm pretty i was pretty good about
it but it's fine
i'll write an email trisha paytas backup
is my second one
ela follows me on there and you do not i
didn't know you had a backup well you do
now so can you follow me sure
that's where we had to announce our
engagement i got deleted the week of our
engagement
oh was that the big announcement you
were because that would have been a
great post i know it was a good post i
got 80 000 on my backup account eighty
thousand likes so
oh eighty thousand that's a really good
way to launch your backup because people
are like oh it's trisha
right banger right ellis can i get
verified on that did you know that
there's like a h
there's like a ton of tick tock videos
of that clip where you go
where i make fun of your vocal fry i see
it like so many times where you go
and i go right um people love us on tech
talk we're kind of everything yeah
i see this a lot it makes me really
happy i always like it i go
sick you snap tick tock you gave up on
tick tock
it's just so hard because i want to make
a good good tick tocks and
it's just so hard not me i just throw up
whatever it's like the name of the game
on there just like throw up anything and
hopefully
you can do it like looking ugly whatever
i i
want to make more tick box it's just
tough did you see me singing hebrew this
morning on tik tok no that was very good
a lot of likes yeah i had like a hundred
thousand one like kind of came on here
what were the comments though the
comments questions
i don't believe it hang on every these
comments
i haven't okay wait
wait what everyone's saying they're
impressed why is this good though
they actually sound good while set
they're like you sound good in hebrew
only
i'll take it i'm going to be an israeli
star
this is too much
something you
whatever who gives a [ __ ] i promise to
be with you forever and be like
your piece cool
whatever but who bought raw through good
and bad let's do the cancellation
everybody's waiting for the cancellation
okay
dan you don't damn you you get so
frustrated
[Music]
yeah shipping okay start over i wasn't
[Music]
of the year trisha paytas
instagram yeah my instagram account is
disabled
[Music]
hey team youtube why was my youtube
account terminated with no warning slash
no strikes for quote sexual content
that he is permanently forever banned
nicocado avocado instagram
[Music]
these are so weird stop leafy youtube
and twitch
whoa am i already banned
i'm already banned oh he should win
that's a good quote
yeah leafy is definitely editing on this
honestly give whoever this was a raise
whoever edits it
this is really good editing i'm like
thank you yeah like it's really
entertaining with the
with this so i like that so account
banned here this is a huge prestigious
award
for me it's got to be between doctor
disrespect
and leafy i did not know dr disrespect
and i barely know leafy but i knew about
levia did not know about doctors because
like those are huge like these guys yeah
leafy's come for me he called me a piggy
a bunch of times yeah well
he won't be doing it now he's banned
all right drumroll account
ban of the year 2020
the winner by a very close margin
is leafy leafy who lost it all
he was banned on youtube and twitch so
that's his livelihood
he's pretty much yeah he's pretty much
off he's like
alex jones like see ya you know what i
mean this is another reason
everyone needs to get married so you
have stability as an influencer like if
i fall off
this one has a degree yeah but what's
the chance that leafy doesn't marry a
deadbeat how's he gonna marry anyone
with a career
[ __ ] yeah you know whatever yeah i am so
leafy
uh is a winner congratulations to leafy
dr disrespect very close second very
close
to 23.5 percent which i think makes
sense because leafy lost like everything
doctor disrespected streaming on youtube
at least
trisha you came in third close third
21.5 my instagram that was shadow band
everyone's like poor trisha
we had to write in paris hilton and uh
gabby
di martino i don't know perez hilton
lost his tick tock he not only did he
lose his tick tock he created two more
tick tock accounts and they banned those
yeah you can't no he had his mom create
one and his sister create one under like
press hilton news and they banned those
thoughts
i was like i don't know anything about
him but dumb ass congratulations leafy
we'll definitely be getting you award
best band creator
of 2020. you may not have any accounts
but you will have this award
that's something you may not have a
career did he have or any income
didn't he disappear though he
disappeared yeah he came back oh
no and then apparently he made another
account where he's he tried to do a
keemstar thing where he's like a company
hired me to do this
and youtube's like banned oh but that's
good for me like you're like my
insurance so if i get banned i'm like
i'm just a host on the a street podcast
channel
why would you get banned i don't know i
literally don't do anything no one cares
about me anymore
yeah yeah don't worry about it um but
that's why it didn't work he got banned
and i keep this as my job security
that's why we're gonna be
excellent we love it and now our i think
our biggest
and final category so here we are
at our final category the biggest one
the most hotly anticipated
category of the night what is the
category ian
this is most dramatic most
dramatic and i'll be ah creator of 2020
the most diverse nominees the most there
was i mean the stiff competition this
year it was it was
let's go ahead and review the nominees
please dan thank you let's do it
most dramatic creator
jaclyn hill austin
mcbroom
gabby hannah jake
paul
[Music]
these are your nominees wow
[Music]
i gotta say i think you're a shoo-in
because that competition doesn't look
that stiff
i think it's safe to say i'm the most
dramatic i try to start beef with
everybody yeah
you know i took a leaf out of your book
recently and i or i think you know but i
went like all
in for david portney i was like [ __ ]
this guy i'm gonna
[ __ ] this kid this guy's such a dude bad
beef to start
he's not super relevant maybe start with
someone like a little more
popular why he's popular not popular
enough where people are gonna get behind
it
you gave him more views where the most
viewed episode was me on the bff so
anyway let's go most dramatic let's get
a drum roll please people most dramatic
creator
and the winner is by an overwhelming
majority
47.1 percent trisha
[Applause]
wow you won there it is
most dramatic creator of the year
they love you they really love you
and we have our very own
frenemies styled
rhinestones steamies
presented to you we're gonna have to get
this engraved that's beautiful patricia
most dramatic creator of 2020.
congratulations wow
wow thank you everybody for joining us
this year
2020 steamies have been an absolute
pleasure congratulations to all our
winners congratulations trisha yeah
and uh congratulations to you guys we
made it out of 2020 let's all go have a
great year
i'm your host stephen klein
thanks for watching
[Music]
you